وانا احييكم مشاهدينا ومتابعينا من جديد
وجد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو نفسه في ازمه من صنعه بعد احداث
العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه في نابلس
نتنياهو في ورطه بسبب قراراته وبسببه
وزرائه المتطرفين بحسب تحليل لشرق الاوسط
التناقض تمثل بارسال رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي في حكومته ورئيس جهاز مخابراته الى
مدينه العقبه للتوقيع على تفهمات حول
الاوضاع في الساحه الاسرائيليه الفلسطينيه
وفي الوقت نفسه دعوته عدد من وزراء
حكومتاهله محو بلده فلسطينيه عن الخريطه
في ظل استمرار اعمال العنف بين مستوطنين
اسرائيليين
وفلسطينيين مراقبون لقرارات نتنياهو
يقولون لا يستطيع رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
الادعاء بانه فوجئ بالاحداث الاخيره فهو
من شكل حكومه من حزب متطرف عدا ان من يعرف
نتنياهو مفاهمه السياسيه يعرف انه منحهم
قوه كبيره لتنفيذ ماربهم السياسيه جعلهم
يكبلون يديه وكل ذلك بوعي كامل منها
حكومه نتنياهو تتالف من احزاب تعرف
باليمنيه واليمنيه المتطرفه وهي حزب
الليكوت بقياده بنيامين نتنياهو حزب
الصهيونيه الدينيه بقياده
بقياده ايتامار بن جبير حزب نوعا بقياده
افيماوز
بي بي سي توصف هذه الاحزاب بالمتطرفه
بمواقفها تجاه العرب وتعكس التيار الدينيه
الصهيونيه المتطرف الذي يشدد على تعزيز
الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
مناقشه هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من الناصره
ودعواوده الكاتب المحلل السياسي اهلا بك
ومن القدس دكتور مصري استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه اهلا بكما
ضيوف واسمح لي ان ابدا من الناصره معك
استاذ وديع في الواقع اليوم مراقبون
يقولون بان نتنياهو وضع نفسه في مازق كبير
بين وعوده للمجتمع الدولي بالتهدئه
تقابله تصعيد او يقابله تصعيد من حكومته
من وزرائه من اليمين المتطرف هل تعتقد بان
نتنياهو فعليا في ورطه ام انه يعلم ما
يفعل
لا انا اعتقد اننا لم يتوقع ان يجد نفسه
بعد شهرين في هذا المازق او في هذه المازق
او هذه الازمات على انواع هناك ثلاثه
ازمات رئيسيه يواجهها نتنياهو الازمه
الاولى هي الخلافات والسجلات الداخليه
العميقه حول موضوع الاصلاحات القضائيه
التي تعتبرها المعارضه انقلابا على
الديمقراطيه الازمه الثانيه ما يرتبط
بالتصعيد الامني مع الجانب الفلسطيني
وتغييب القضيه الفلسطينيه وتغييب الملف
السياسي والبحث العقيم عن حلول امنيه فقط
ولازم الثالثه وهي مرتبطه بالازمتين
السابقتين هي هذه التصدعات او التوترات
الاوليه داخل الائتلاف الحاكم خاصه وان
بعض
المشاركين في هذا الائتلاف بعض الاحزاب
كان من المتوقع ان تسبب هذا الصداع
لنتنياهو وهو المسؤول عن ذلك لانه سبق وقد
عمل على توحيدها وعلى اطلاق قوتها
وبالتالي انقلب السحر على الساحر
حولت هذه الاحزاب وانا اتحدث عن الصهيونيه
الدينيه وعن القوى اليهوديه حكومه نتنياهو
الى ما يشبه الكاريكاتير فبعد ساعه من
الاعلان عن مخرجات قمه العقبه صار عزيران
رئيسيان في حكومته للقول انما كان في
العقبه سيبقى في العقبه وهذا لن يلزمناه
فهذا احد اسباب الحرج وبالتالي هناك يعني
بدايه تساؤلات وهناك يضاف الى ذلك طبعا
سجلات وانتقادات متبادله بين حزب اللكود
الحاكم دراسه نتناول بين هذين الحسبين
وهذه المره الاولى يضاف الى ذلك استقاله
نائب
وزير وهو رئيس حزب نوعه في اسرائيل في نوع
من اليوم عاده السدود تنهار وتتدفق المياه
بقوه وتدمر امامها من خلال ثغره صغيره انا
اعتقد ان اليوم كانت بدايه هذا التحلل
بدايه العد التنازل في حكومتين وحتى قال
ذلك اكثر من شهور ولكن لا شك ان نتنياهو
يجد نفسه في هامش مناوره ضيق امام الضغوط
الخارجيه والداخليه وحتى واوساط واسعه في
اليمين في اسرائيل لا تثق بقدره بعض
الوزراء المركزيين خاصه المسؤولين عن
الامن من لا يكون بقدره هؤلاء من اداره
الملف الامني
كيف لنتنياهو الا يدرك توجهات وزرائه يعني
ان كان المراقب البسيط الذي يتابع
الشان الاسرائيلي يعرف تقريبا طبيعه
وتوجهات بنكير مثلا من خلال تصريحاته وحتى
افعاله فما بالك بنتنياهو هل وضع نفسه في
ورطه هل ورطوه هل هي الظروف
ك الكريم الاستاذ وديع
اولا لدى اسرائيل متطرفين كما انه لدى
السلطه الفلسطينيه متطرفين انا اتحدث عن
حماس واخواتها نتحدث عن السلطه الفلسطينيه
بعد العمل الارهابي الشنيع الذي قام
بهذه نتحدث عن الشان الاسرائيلي
اقول انه التطرف موجود في اسرائيل كما هو
موجود في السلطه الرئيس الفلسطيني محاط
بعده عده قيادات داخل حركه فتح طلب
الانسحاب من اجتماع العقبه تماما كما انه
قوه تطرف الراديكاليه داخل حكومه
انهما وقع عليه في العقبه سوف يظل في
العقبه اذا نحن هناك حقيقه ام اشكاليه وهي
اشكاليه تنامي قوى التطرف سواء في اورشليم
القدس او في رام الله لكن على ارض الواطيه
الكريمه الليكود ممسك بالزمام الامور
نتنياهو هو عنوان الحكومه وانا لست مصادر
نتنياه الحاله لم انتخبه ولس
ت على العقول انها الازمه التي نواجهها
اليوم هي اندلعت في
عهد الحكومه التغيير برئاسه بين التقييد
حيث انها بدات العمليات الامنيه
الاسرائيليها مناطق حقيقه الفقراتها
الاجهزه الامنيه الفلسطينيه وفقا
لاتفاقيات المبرمه الاتفاقيات اوستو هذه
المناطق لا يجوز ان تصبح مرتعا للجهاديين
والارهابيين وبالتالي اسرائيل تدخل حيث
تنسحب السلطه لا نتحدث فقط عن هذه المناطق
دكتور نحن نتحدث كذلك عن المسجد الاقصى
وتعلم حضرتك ما الذي حدث في نتحدث عن
انتهاكات بنك فيرون نتحدث في المقابل عن
وعود نتنياهو بتهدئه هذا ما وعد به
المجتمع الدولي وهنا سؤال كيف سيحقق هذه
المعادله الصعبه
اعتقد انه قوى التطرف في اسرائيل هي فقط
حنجريه هي تتحدث فقط يعني مساله
يعني هو ليس المسجد الاقصى ولكن في مكان
قريب للغايه من المنزل الاقصى نسميه جبل
الهيكل وهي كانت زياره 13 دقيقه
هذا المكان تفقدوا زياره تفقديه كوزير
الامن الداخلي وقبله وزراء اخرين من ضمنهم
الوزير اردان الذي اصبح فيه المتحده ولم
يتحدث اي احد عن هذه الزياره لان المشكله
لم تكن في زياره وانما كانت في الزائر
صحيح هو شخص متطرف
والجيش الاسرائيلي لفظه ولم يقبل به حينما
كان عمره 18 عاما بسبب طبعا لو كان شخصا
مشاغبا في السابق تحققت معه الشرطه 54 مره
في السابق دخل السجن اكثر في اكثر من
مناسبه وبالتالي هؤلاء دعم هذه
صحيح ولكن سلمه
سلمه نتنياهو مهام مهام كبيره ااا سيد
وديع ان كان لك اولا تعليق على ما تفضل به
ضيفنا الدكتور
اولا بنجفير لم يعتقل فقط لقد ادينا
بمحاكم الاسرائيليه بالارهاب وهو وزير
الامن الداخلي الان صحيح انه لم يزر سوى
13 دقيقه ولكن هي دقيقه واحده كافيه ان
تنتهك المقدسات لكن قبل ان يزور الحرم
القدسي الشريف كان تعيين مثل هذا الرجل في
هذا المنصب بمثابه استفزاز لكل الشعب
الفلسطيني على طرفي الخط الاخضر فكان هذا
الرجل يملا الدنيا وعودا بتاديب
الفلسطينيين
وبالاعتداء عليهم وكان يتوعد ويتهدد ولذلك
هذا التعيين جاء بمثابه اصبع في عين
الفلسطينيين ولذلك الحديث لا يدور فقط عن
سياسات وعن جوهر انما يدور ايضا عن اسلوب
استفزازي يعتمد للتلويح بالقوه ومحاوله
حسم الصراع بالحديد والنار دفع
الفلسطينيين الى حاله من يعني الحساسيه
انهم مضطرون لان يردون على مثل هذه
السياسات ومثل هذه التوجهات نعم ولذلك انا
اقول اننا مقبلون على المزيد من التصعيد
والمزيد من التوتر وما يرتبط بسؤالك الاول
هذا سينعكس سلبا ايضا على تماسك وسلامه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لان ببساطه وانا
اتحدث الان وفق مصطلحات وموازين ومقاييس
اسرائيليه حسب المصلحه الاسرائيليه لا
يمكن للاسرائيليين ان يرضوا بمثل هذه
الحكومه المجنونه التي تعمل يعني بكثير من
الحالات بشكل غير اخلاقي وبشكل منفلت وتصب
الزيت على النار بشكل مجنون وينذر بالمزيد
من المخاطر وعليه دكتور مئر هذه المعادله
هل يمكن اعتبارها معادله صعبه ام معادله
مستحيله قادره ان تطيح بحكومه نتنياهو هذه
المعادله نتحدث عن كيف لنتنياهو ان يلتزم
بوعوده للخارج وفي نفس الوقت ان يحافظ على
التماسك حكومته
نعم هذه صحيح اشكاليه نحن كنا نتمنى ان
تقوم حكومه واحده وطنيه في اسرائيل
نتنياهو لم يكن لم يرغب في ان يعين بيلفيل
على راس وزاره الشرطه ووزاره الامن
الداخليه وانما هذه هي قواعد اللعبه
الانتخابيه داخل اسرائيل نظام نيابي هناك
مفاوضات التشكيله الائتلاف في اطار النظام
القائم وبالتالي لم يكن هذا الخيارا
لكوديا او خيارا بل كانت يعني اقل
الخيارات اقل الخيارات المره حقيقه ولكن
مره اخرى انا اعتقد انه
الطابع السياسي للحكومه هو جزء من المشكله
ولكنه جزء صغير ليس
هو حيث انه الازمه التي نواجهها اندلعت في
ظل كما ذكرت الحكومه
الحكومه اعتقد انه
معنيه بالتصعيد او معنيه هي معنيه
بالتهديد يبقى يبقى السؤال كل هذا قادر ان
يطيح بحكومه نتنياهو
انا لا اظن لا اعتقد ذلك لانه نتنياهو
يتمتع
64 مقعد في الكنيست من وهو يمثل القوى
النيابيه الاكبر في الكنيست لدي اكثر من
ربع المقاعد كاليكوت لا اعتقد انه هناك
خطر على استمراريه حكمه او على استقرار
الائتلاف الحاكم ولكن لا شك انه يجب ان
تؤخذ اجراءات وهذا وصدق يجب ان تساعد
اسرائيل على ذلك نتحدث عن العناصر
المتطرفه داخل الحكومه ولكن على طرف الاخر
كذلك نحن على يعني على جميع شاشات باللغه
الانجليزيه للرئيسه فلسطيني وهو يدين
العمل الارهابي ولكن نائبه نائبه باللغه
العربيه
دعم هذا العمل وقال انه عمل فدائي وثوري
وما شبه ذلك هناك تناقضات يجب ان تحل
ضيفكم الكريم صديق من الناصره الاستاذ
وديع هو كذلك خطابي في نوع من التناقض هو
يقول انه لا يمكن انه رد فعل انه الارهاب
وهذا رد فعل طبيعي
لحاله
الياس الذي نحن فيه اليوم طبعا من عدم
تقدم في عمليه السلميه ولكن هذا التناقض
لماذا لانه في نفس الوقت الذي يكون له رد
فعل طبيعي نحن نرى ان هناك شاب وادانا من
قبل رئيس السلطه الف
لسطينيه هذا العمل بانه كذلك من يقوم بهذه
العمليه هو غير عمليه السلام حماس
ما وصفته بتناقض الاستاذ وديع استاذ وديع
ان كنت استمعت لضيفي تعليقك على ما اعتبره
تناقضا في طرحك او في قراءتك للوضع
اولا نتنياهو بنفسه ويتحدث عن ضرورات
ائتلافيه وديمقراطيه ووجود احزاب وبالتالي
هناك نظام نيابه اذكر الضيفك بان نتنياهو
بنفسه هو الذي كان قد جمع شمل هؤلاء
الوزراء المتطرفين في قائمه واحده ولذلك
انقلب السحر على الساحر ثانيا نتنياهو
صاحب القرار ولذلك ما يجري في حواره وما
يجري من انتهاكات صحيح هذا يتم من خلال
المستوطنين او من خلال اسراء متطرفين ولكن
المسؤوليه تقع على عاتق نتنياهو وما كنت
هو يعني افعال الحكومه الاحتلال تتناقض مع
القولون الدولي بشكل صريح تتناكد مع
الاخلاق ولكن انتبهي ايضا تتناقض مع
المصلحه السياسيه الاسرائيليه
المصلحه الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه هذا
التورط مواقع ثنائي القوميه هذا التسخين
هذا الضغط الذي سيدفع الفلسطينيين الى
الانفجار كما وان كانوا داخل طنجره ضغط
هذا ما يعيه بعض العقلاء ويحذرون منه وكل
من يحاول ان يدافع عن نتنياهو سياسات
نتنياهو هذه الحكومه باشكال مختلفه ولا
يضر بالفلسطينيين فقط ولا ينتهك القانون
الدولي فقط انما يمس ايضا بمصلحه
اسرائيليه عليا هذه العمليات الفلسطينيه
التي تعود ايضا كيدا مرتدا على الاحتلال
وعلى الاسرائيليين يستطيع الاسرائيليون ان
يساهمون في محاوله منعها او التخفيف منها
لان ببساطه ما يتعرض له الفلسطينيون يؤدي
الى ردود فعل من هذا القبيل وردود فعلا
دوليه كذلك شكرا جزيلا لكم على مشاركتنا
هذا النقاش من الناصره
من القدس دكتور ماهر مصري استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه شكرا لكما